hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
candy's - now we're on the fourth night
which means that things are gonna plug
get a lot harder as far as I know I've
been told that there are a total of nine
animatronics including one super secret
super duper ultra of animatronic did I
get did more trash appear on my table
cuz that's probably gonna be a bad thing
for littering and [ __ ] but hello but
also um in addition to the animatronic
set are normally there which I believe
there's a total of eight and I'm now not
you oh hi
god damn it oh god oh god this is a bad
start to this oh I didn't mean to do
that
ah pan whose yeah there we go that was a
lucky guess at best I gotta turn up my
volume I can't hear nothing oh this is
off to a bad start
I barely woke up oh god okay so that got
ripped out of its cord
you two are there hello No thank you
that's probably gonna be oh hello it's
gonna be on a sooner and sooner timer as
time goes on oh okay this is you man
they move fast it's not ideal
I got damnit I'm trying to fiddle with
my audio because I can't quit oh that's
not the right there we go okay good then
you're gonna go over there who's here
nobody
okay so there's generally okay there's
no one new add into the mix which is a
good thing and also I wanted to
reiterate I'm very sorry obviously this
video is coming at you way way way late
as what it's supposed to be because
everyone that was over at our house
including the kyer families now on their
way back home and we had a good time
while they were here we caught up a lot
and we got to talk but that's kind of
being pushed aside in terms of the cry
sick of the panic [ __ ] oh god damn it oh
okay wow this is whoa
Nate for is a lot more intense than I
thought it'd be hey yeah nervous
laughter makes me happier makes me feel
like everything's gonna be okay but so
this video is coming way late and
unfortunately I'm only gonna be able to
get one video up today but tomorrow
ah
hello thank you for the convenience crap
no thank you
tomorrow I'm gonna have three videos out
today to try to make up for it it's a
little too late in the day for me to try
to get three up today or two up today
here but I will make up for it I do try
to stick to the schedule but tomorrow
everything should be hunky-dory I just
was not able to record any videos or
spare any time to get away from the
guests that we're at the house this is a
bit too much for me it's a bit too much
god damn it you're not in the right spot
stop you there we go God who's almost
died if I can thank you Jesus I'm not
okay with this I'm gonna die in horrible
ways if I can roll through this night I
will roll on the night five and then oh
could you need to die over there there
over and over again cuz Ryan this is
weird okay there's only three
animatronics out right now as far as I
know oh hello ah forgot about sassy
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
aw [ __ ] okay we're fine everything's
fine good think that thing was ringing
over there
and almost entirely forgotten about that
hello goodbye okay since it seems to be
the same I'll come back when there's
something different BRB [ __ ] no that's
not what I wanted okay made its mean 4
a.m. we're doing fine that rebooted
rather quickly thank you for that holy
crap holy crap holy crap I'm gonna die
Hey look traffic's gonna murder me and
then I'm gonna not live anymore because
that's how dying works alright [ __ ] [ __ ]
it nah [ __ ]
check okay so we're almost through hello
they get they they suddenly I swear they
suddenly got a lot more active and I'm
really lucky that that wasn't it done
like that trying to just dance them
around the entire complex but it's
getting rather difficult if go I keep
checking the main hallway just in case
there's another animatronic that wants
to show his face up to me but I'm
thing that they're all too scared at how
amazingly handsome and/or strong I am
and then I want to tangle with a lights
markiplier probably who the hell is
banging I still don't know what's gonna
happen if Jojo actually gets into the
vents actually I know exactly what's
gonna happen it's gonna murder my face
okay but other than that Oh God whoa
whoa just stop just generally stop Oh
Teddy T's T's titties get away get away
get away get away get away get away get
away get away get away get away you stop
there then you go here then you go there
then you go [ __ ] yourself
and then you go eat a dick and then you
go away have a good one unless you enjoy
eating dicks and have a nice day god
dammit I I keep forgetting that I
actually need to click away when I see
Pangu come on six I haven't got any time
okay
that's girl crap that's the one okay man
it is just a fly there we go hey alright
Wow damn hot tits holy balls okay what
awaits us now how is this too much too
much for my heart to handle sooo bad
that I'm good at this game
Oh return return what return both of us
am I supposed to hold your hand on this
one hello hi friend okay
goodbye candy Cindy's off to see
something I don't know what I'm supposed
to be returning but it's entirely
possible that I'm split it has something
to do with how Jojo is all disassembled
like I don't think I can go up to the
room where Jojo was Oh what is that is
that a tie was that JoJo's tied to Jojo
even wear a tie
I have multiple questions in association
with that uh with that object that I
have in my possession now oh did candy
have a tie but I would have assumed that
it was a bow tie but maybe not
would you like your tie back call well
that seemed like a fruitless task why
was that my job all right whatever
let's do this name five I'm rolling
right through forget all you guys I'm
gonna see what this night five is all
about and if there's gonna be another
animatronic to haunt my dreams also it's
still a little bizarre that there's no
like phone call or messages or anything
in between I'm just at my heart a dumb
person that decided that it would be a
good idea to come to haunted an old
abandoned warehouse in middle of night
and stay here five day what do I do
about you I don't know what I do about
you I don't know I know about you I know
no I know about you what do I do about
you oh that's not good oh that's not
good oh that's not good to hear oh
that's not good oh that's not I how's
going are you doing friend friend where
are you going
where is Ren going I don't know I don't
know how to do all my phones is be broke
obviously he is just making his way
downtown walking fast holy [ __ ] that's
broken oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no not you too oh
god he's gonna get in oh god my god
oh my god oh [ __ ] okay [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I'm
dead I'm dead a million ways I'm dead
oh I'm so dead
not just some good her what do I do
about that
then why would I jump I said why would I
do about you Jesus
all righty then seventeen-year-old
Marilyn Schmitt the really really really
stupid person that stayed five nights in
a row at this place to prove to her
friends that she was the baddest of
asses I don't know what to do about that
one that's new and interesting maybe I'm
not supposed to look at him cuz looking
is deaf I don't know try that again I
have a feeling it's gonna end up the
same way cuz I don't know yet
oh boy okay so if Blanc was coming at me
and it's not cool it's not I want to be
very clear by that it's not cool what
it's happening
so if Blanc gonna do dad what do I get
what are we gonna follow you you freak
the Frank the big Tom what did you pull
it out what are you doing if you did
that you don't like the phone no no okay
I was about to say so that [ __ ]
Blanc oh god oh god damn it
I [ __ ] oh that ain't good set oh hi
wait are you back there oh [ __ ]
God why are you back here oh god oh god
oh god
oh why I prophets with the game broke
aah band bag bag bag
I found Berg they won watching it big I
found in the game broke anybody Jojo I'm
just gonna wait here and see if Jojo
eventually gets into them
Oh scary oohs
yes can I help you sir no my full okay
the game thoroughly broke yeah
your be okay we're back let's get back
into the game because that was not a
good try anyway so I'm gonna give it a
one more good try and if I can't get out
of this one cuz for some reason Blanc
made Lukey loop I don't know why he made
a loop de loop buddy Luke looped oh hi
how's it goin there
God you are so handsome I don't think
he's attracted by the sound I think he
just kind of skipped it over maybe he
just doesn't like to be looked at
why's our rumbling wait what no no that
makes no Zed hello are you there that
major says what is it I'm AJ's where I
thank you don't do that [ __ ] [ __ ] I
don't like
oh god why hello what what you just
choose randomly I don't understand how
you work sir and I would appreciate it I
would appreciate it if you would explain
your antics a little more effectively
oh [ __ ] what what the [ __ ] hey kid you
hi are you just following me are you
following goddammit are you you are
methinks you maybe you are you are a
[ __ ] and I don't like you and I would
wish that you don't do hello goodbye
alright then Oh God uh I'm so confused
I was Oh confused I got damnit I'm so
confused
like none of this makes any sense
are they all getting out of the way so
the blank can have his fun I think that
I forgot that not looking at him doesn't
make him go away
got it she's some sort of Slenderman
mechanic not you not you either not you
never [ __ ] Oh God hello okay I guess I
lucked out then great this is the best
for the [ __ ] guy hi
okay bye I guess where are you banging
good it would better not have been the
other one that I didn't want you to not
be banging at [ __ ] you brah come on give
me some goddamned break the tips a
sandbags [ __ ] or ducks I don't know
so either he goes where I'm looking and
he kind of follows McGee's hello oh okay
pile-up on here which is good cuz that
means that I I just need to be looking
that okay if my fear is correct if I
stay well let me do this if I stay
looking down this hallway eventually
he's gonna show up maybe maybe maybe not
okay my theory is very wrong I actually
have no idea what's going on which is
very similar to everything else that I'd
hello are you there maybe I'm not
supposed to be looking at you I don't
know is that it am I not supposed to be
looking at him cuz if I look at him too
long he doesn't like to be looked at cuz
he's so frickin ugly his half of his
face is missing like a frickin [ __ ]
like what did you do did you fall into
an industrial meat grinder and then
something bad happened to you and your
family rejected you because you were so
horribly ugly is that what happened
blankie blue probably I [ __ ] God what
the buttons were well blankie let's go
back to the horrible travesty that is
your face oh look at that angle
that's not your good angle not that you
have a good angle but everything about
that face just reminds me that I want to
throw up okay so he's on the way because
I'm insulting him non-stop but also like
I think he just if I follow him around
the circuit he's just not happy number
one but he wants me to look at him like
what kind of horror show with a face
like that would want people to look at
him I mean she's so unbelievably ugly I
mean you look at someone and you're kind
of like oh that's a face only a mother
could love that mother threw him to the
curb as soon as she took one gander at
how horribly horrendously ugly it was
and I say it because it's obviously not
a person because a person could not be
that ugly
are we clear blank you're [ __ ] ugly
you're fugly is [ __ ]
okay I don't think he likes me okay
where's blank kind of lost track of him
there he is
oh man you call him one name and he
comes a-running
oh maybe someone that can appreciate my
ugliness nope
you're horrible crippling ugliness is a
ruin to everyone around you you should
just go in hiding live as a hermit
underneath a rock with a bag over your
head and then I'm not in good shape
that's not a good thing that's not the
right place this is [ __ ] I'm dead why
why have you done this to me
I sure I got too caught up in insulting
him but I kind of forgot that I needed
to play the game I was so I was having
so much fun there [ __ ]
okay so I'll get to I'll beat this night
in the next episode that's guaranteed
and remember I'm very sorry for the
delays this week it's just been crazy
with so many people coming out of town
so thank you everybody for your patience
tomorrow everything will be back on
schedule and I'll be about three videos
for you guys to make up for missing it
today thank you everybody for
understanding and thank you everybody
for watching and as always I will see
you
in the next video